dernière échéance avant la primaire de
la droite du 9 septembre
les politiques ont défilé à jouy en
josas à l'université d'été du medef pour
rencontrer et conquérir les
entrepreneurs présents les intervenants
que ça soit françois fillon hier nicolas
sark du ce matin où bruno le maire et
puis cet après midi alain juppé
effectivement souhaite faire bouger les
choses mais ils ont déjà été également
pour pouvoir en tous les cas pour faire
pincer des choses ont bougé mais ne
bougent pas suffisamment les plénières
sont très orientés politique mais il
reste encore des interventions très
ciblées notamment sur le tourisme dans
l'espace innovation qui sont assez
intéressants avec des belles tables
rondes donc effectivement ça couvre sur
tout l'espace médiatique sur le reste il
ya quand même du fond et des conférences
assez intéressante sur votre sujet deux
jours pour parler des problématiques et
économique
la 18e édition a eu lieu la semaine
dernière au campus dash c'est un moment
pour faire le bilan de l'année écoulée
et ses futurs prospectives
c'est au sénat où on lance des idées on
les thèmes de réflexion et des ateliers
où on travaille c'est également un avoir
de rencontres entre les formes de
mouvements d et des autres c'est
beaucoup d'invités des politiques
conférences débats et tables rondes se
sont succédé autour des thèmes de la
conquête
l'audace ou encore l' enthousiasme avec
un slogan cette année y croire et agir
c'est un appel et j'espère que vale
politique les dirigeants de swiss qui
sont là l'ont entendu et c'est important
pour les jeunes pour les nouvelles
générations d'entendre ça et de change
et du climat actuel que l'on à une
édition très politisé marquée par la
démission des manuels macron mais aussi
son absence comme celle de représentants
du gouvernement